Do you recommend clear, multi-bind for most people?
Well, not everybody needs it.
So, certainly in the summertime,
if you're out sweating a lot or if you're doing sodas on a regular basis,
taking a mineral supplement is good.
If you're taking the greens, supplements,
and you're eating real well and you're eating,
where do you get your minerals from and your diet?
You get your minerals from your vegetables.
So, if you're for people who in general,
for people who are like not big vegetable eaters,
they don't eat a lot of salads,
they don't like a lot of vegetables,
or their idea of vegetables is corn.
Corn is a grade not a vegetable.
So, if that's their idea of vegetables,
they're probably deficient to minerals,
and yes, they should be taking a product like clear multi-bind.
But even for our patients, you know,
most of our patients are eating really well,
eating better than they have in their life,
some of them taking the green supplement,
well, clear multi-bind,
is it necessarily necessary for everybody?
So, the reason why we use the clear multi-bind
is it's iron-free,
because why would you want to not be on iron?
Well, iron is highly inflammatory.
If you're deficient and you have anemia,
then you may need to be on an iron.
But if you're not,
if you're not endemic,
then you shouldn't be taking iron.
And you shouldn't be taking iodine.
If you have any hint of any possible
Hashimoto's thyroid issues
or other autoimmune issues,
you want to limit your iodine levels.
So, that's why we picked that product.